i'm really excited to get the chance to
talk to you about this show i just
finished watching the first season last
night and i have so many questions none
of which i can actually talk about
because they are like yeah
but um i would love to go back with you
and ask about kind of your history with
this show how familiar were you with the
franchise before you signed on so i only
knew the movie so i didn't even realize
that it was based on video games so i
didn't even know that the movies were
based on the video games so um when it
first came to me
that was the movie's really anything
that came were in my head i had the good
fortune of being able to read the first
seven episodes
uh they were written already before i
even met met on the project so
um what drew me to the show was the
character and the story and how well it
was written so basically and i'm curious
about how you were cast they approached
you
specifically in mind for this role and
then you kind of got a chance to see
what their plans were before
even saying yes no no for no no not no
so i i'm still kind of amazed that my
that my agent actually had the first
seven of seven episodes already in
retrospect uh they did not approach me
for the role
uh i read them
that i was like i want to do this
then
call netflix like we're seeing a lot of
people
my manager's like
well he had an audition for season 20
he's not going to do that so he called
the show runner
sona was like last round great idea let
me talk to the other producers tom dale
producers last week a great idea so then
i ended up meeting with the producers in
the show the other producers in the show
running um and that's how i got the job
i was pleasantly surprised by how much
stunt action you get to perform in this
show
um some really badass stuff so what was
that like to train for how did that feel
to kind of play out on the actual day of
filming well i um i try to
generally i try to keep in shape and
because i kind of knew where the story
was going i i um
i i was working out almost every day you
know for the first four months before we
even got shooting that stuff
um
and then
i had
a i didn't say i didn't have a lot but i
had some stunt training you know we
choreographed everything i had a couple
days of choreography before we actually
shot there was there's a big scene at
the at the restaurant and then there um
there there are two other stuff things
one which i can't really get into
because it's spoiled spoiler territory
um but um it was just about kind of
staying loose and staying in shape well
without going into too much spoilers
territory wesker is a character who
presents initially as one very specific
type of man but then we start to see
many different i would say facets to his
character as the show goes on um
what did you enjoy most about getting to
play all those different sides of him
i
it sounds like the most pedestrian thing
when i got what i enjoyed most about
playing all those different sides of him
was getting to play all those different
sides of him you know as an actor you
always want to do something different
and that was another reason one of the
reasons why i was so drawn to this is
because i was like well i haven't played
a guy like this before and i really want
to do that um but you're always looking
to play
something
different and unique so having a
character that has so many different
facets it's almost like getting a bunch
of different jobs in one job well
personally i was really excited to get
to see you express so many different
sides of this character i think fans are
going to be surprised to see all the
different layers to albert wesker um as
well as the relationship with his
daughters which i think is really
something that just is the heart of the
show
but thank you so much for taking the
time to talk to me about the show uh
it's a blast and and i'm really excited
for everyone else to get to see it thank
you
you